zone Europe sur sensation
bonsoir et bienvenue dans zone Europe
sur Radio sensation et sur TV 78 pour
une émission spéciale enregistrée ici au
salon de l'agriculture qui dit Europe et
agriculture d'ipaque la politique
agricole commune représente à elle seule
387 milliards d'euros pour la période
2023 2027 ça représente à peu près un
tiers du budget européen on en parle
avec Catherine Ghlin Lanel elle est
directrice de la stratégie et de
l'analyse politique de la direction
générale de l'agriculture de la
Commission européenne
bonjour Catherine merci d'être avec nous
alors ça y est la nouvelle Pâque est
entrée en vigueur le 1er janvier 2023 la
PAC c'est l'une des politiques majeures
de l'Union européenne pour cette pack
donc 2023 2027 plusieurs changements ont
vu le jour on va en parler avec vous une
mets d'abord revenons un peu sur sur
cette histoire sur cette pack donc qui a
été mise en place en 1962 qu'elles
étaient au départ les objectifs initiaux
donc en effet la politique agricole
commune ou la Pâque comme on l'appelle
et la plus ancienne politique européenne
elle a été d'ailleurs le moteur de
l'Union européenne à l'époque qui
s'appelait la Communauté économique
européenne très longtemps et en fait on
sortait de la guerre et on avait besoin
de développer la production agricole et
alimentaire de ce qui était la
Communauté économique européenne avec à
l'époque six pays fondateurs et donc on
a créé une politique qui a cherché à
inciter les agriculteurs à produire plus
de toutes sortes de produits produits
animaux produits végétaux à des prix
raisonnables pour les consommateurs et
elle a très bien fonctionné à tel point
d'ailleurs que dans les années 70-80
elle a tellement bien fonctionné en
améliorant le revenu des agriculteurs et
en produisant de grandes quantités qu'on
a été obligé de la réformer pour faire
en sorte que on n'est pas des stocks
très importants de produits agricoles et
alimentaires et ça n'a été que la
première d'une succession de réforme
pour une politique qui s'est toujours
adaptée à la demande des consommateurs
et de la société européenne alors
justement ces objectifs initiaux qui
sont produire plus à des prix
intéressants aussi pour les agriculteurs
ça constitue le premier pilier de la de
la PAC en 1999 il y a eu ce deuxième
pilier avec donc le FEDER qui a été
introduit le Fonds européen agricole
pour le développement rural il est géré
par l'État et les régions directement il
conçu donc ce deuxième pilier
concrètement à quoi il sert
va chercher au travers de ce deuxième
pilier d'une part à mieux prendre en
compte la place de l'agriculture dans
les zones rurales et la vie en milieu
rural donc en finançant avec ce deuxième
pilier toute une série d'actions en
particulier des investissements dans les
zones rurales essentiellement agricoles
mais pas seulement il y a aussi des
infrastructures non agricoles et aussi
le financement d'un certain nombre
d'aides et je mentionnerai ici parce que
ça a été le début j'allais dire du
renforcement du caractère vert de la
pacte on a financé les aides à
l'agriculture biologique agriculture qui
a connu un développement considérable
depuis ces dernières années
effectivement une des nouveautés donc
principale de cette pack pour la période
2023 2027 ce sont les plans stratégiques
nationaux alors désormais les États
doivent envoyer à la commission un plan
national stratégique pour pouvoir
bénéficier ensuite des fonds qu'est-ce
qu'il contiennent ces plans et à quoi
ils servent alors vous avez raison c'est
une grande nouveauté on garde des
objectifs communs au 27 pays de l'Union
mais on tient compte du fait qu'il y a
une très grande diversité de
l'agriculture dans les différents pays
de l'Union européenne et donc sur la
base de 10 objectifs communs fixés au
niveau européen et d'une Boîte à outils
aussi qui est européenne boîte à outils
c'est-à-dire modalités de financement
instruments financier on propose aux
États membres d'établir ce qu'on appelle
des plans stratégiques dans laquelle ils
vont décrire les caractéristiques de
leur agriculture les objectifs qui sont
prioritaires pour eux en fonction des
défis auxquels leur agriculture est
soumise et la manière dont ils vont
utiliser cette boîte à outils et ses
financements européens donc chaque État
membre a proposé son plan stratégique
national à la Commission européenne
l'année dernière et donc au sein de
cette commission européenne la direction
générale de l'Agriculture a étudié
j'imagine ces plans stratégie nationaux
certains ont été retoqués il y a eu des
négociations ça s'est passé plus ou
moins facilement ça c'est bien passé je
dirais c'est à dire qu'il y a eu un
échange évidemment
un temps assez court il y avait un an
pour valider ses plans stratégiques pour
ils entrent en vigueur à partir du 1er
janvier 2023 il y a eu des échanges pour
s'assurer aussi qu'il y avait une
cohérence entre ces plantes qui
respectaient bien les objectifs qui
avaient été fixés par les États membres
de l'Union européenne lors de la
négociation de l'impact et donc ils ont
tous été validés avant la fin de l'année
2022 ce qui leur a permis d'être mis en
oeuvre dès le 1er janvier de cette année
donc autre nouveauté de cette pack ce
sont aussi ces éco régimes alors qui ont
vocation à encourager les bonnes
pratiques environnementales de la part
des agriculteurs 25% des aides directes
ils sont consacrés c'est vraiment
l'aspect environnemental aujourd'hui qui
est prime sur la sur les politiques
c'est un peu le c'est le nouvel
engagement de l'Union européenne avec
notamment pour être cohérent avec le
pacte vert européen
on accent
la dimension environnementale et
j'ajouterai climatique dans le soutien
aux agriculteurs donc d'une PAC qui
était dans les années 60 tournées vers
produire plus on est aujourd'hui dans
une PAC qui est simplement produit mais
produit plus avec moins et mieux en
respectant l'environnement et en
protégeant le climat donc vous avez
raison une désinnovations c'est ce qu'on
appelle c'est
eco-ski mais en français on dirait c'est
ces schémas ou ces instruments
écologiques on va dire qui permettent
aux agriculteurs de bénéficier d'une
rémunération pour les services qu'il
rendent à l'environnement comme par
exemple des pratiques qui vont permettre
de protéger la faune de protéger la
flore d'améliorer la qualité du sol etc
enfin pour finir une expression revient
souvent cette année au Salon de
l'agriculture c'est vu le contexte
géopolitique on le comprend aussi c'est
donc la souveraineté alimentaire
est-ce que le monde agricole doit-il
être au cœur de notre autonomie
stratégique européenne je répondrai oui
à cette question l'alimentation c'est un
enjeu de sécurité c'est un enjeu de
souveraineté on l'a vu avec la guerre en
Ukraine qui a malheureusement impacté
les exportations de l'Ukraine en
céréales vers de nombreux pays qui sont
dépendants dans le monde et qui se
trouvent dans des situations
d'insécurité alimentaire très graves ça
n'a pas été le cas de l'Europe donc on a
peut-être réalisé à nouveau on repris
conscience du caractère stratégique
d'être capable de produire l'essentiel
de son alimentation ça veut pas dire
qu'on importe pas ça veut pas dire qu'on
est exporte pas mais ça veut dire que on
est capable nous les européens notamment
grâce à l'impact et surtout grâce aux
agriculteurs et à toute la chaîne
alimentaire de se nourrir nous-mêmes et
ça c'est très important merci Catherine
Gélin merci d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes directrice de la
stratégie de l'analyse politique de la
Direction de l'Agriculture de la
Commission européenne
zone Europe
l'importance du secteur agricole pour
l'économie l'Union européenne comme
puissance agricole on en parle avec
Marie-pierre vedren elle est heureux
débuter membre du groupe prinus Europe
et vice-présidente de la Commission du
commerce international au Parlement
européen
bonjour Alors l'agriculture c'est aussi
le commerce la France représente un peu
moins de 20% de la production agricole
totale de l'Union européenne une année
2022 marquée par l'inflation et
l'augmentation des prix ce qui a
entraîné donc un excédent commercial
agricole et agroalimentaire français de
10,3 milliards d'euros un record depuis
2013 mais la production albc est-ce que
c'est une bonne nouvelle ce chiffre ou
bien c'est un succès en trompe l'oeil je
pense qu'il faut analyser ces chiffres
de manière à 360 en quelque sorte c'est
déjà positif d'avoir une balance
commerciale sur ce secteur qui est
positive parce qu'on le voit bien on a
une balance commerciale déficitaire pour
l'ensemble de notre balance commerciale
donc avec l'aéronautique le secteur
agroalimentaire et positif donc ça doit
nous interpeller effectivement de voir
comment la France continue de produire
continue à d'exporter mais on le voit
bien nous sommes confrontés au choc du
changement climatique et l'agriculture
la question de souveraineté nous devons
aussi appuyer nos agriculteurs nos
éleveurs pour faire face à ces enjeux
donc je pense que les chiffres sont une
chose mais on le voit bien
spécifiquement avec les échanges que
nous avons sur ce salon international
nous devons réfléchir au futur de la
politique agricole commune nos futures
de notre souveraineté alimentaire et
c'est important de débattre de ces
enjeux parce que la guerre en Ukraine
nous le rappelle l'alimentation est
aussi une arme de guerre alors justement
cette guerre on en a beaucoup parlé
surtout sur ces conséquences
énergétiques on a beaucoup vous parler
du concept de souveraineté énergétique
est-ce qu'il faut faire la même chose
pour le concept de souveraineté
alimentaire
de la République depuis son discours de
la Sorbonne pour dire qu'il nous faut
une Europe plus souveraine c'est-à-dire
qui soit capable de déterminer par
elle-même avec qui quand comment elle
échange mais surtout qui est une
capacité industrielle beaucoup plus
forte le choc du covid nous la démontré
à quel point c'était important notamment
sur les questions de santé la guerre en
Ukraine ou le démonte sur les questions
énergétiques nous étions nous sommes
souvent dépendants en plus de
partenaires qui veulent nous détruire en
quelque sorte qui ne partage pas les
mêmes modèles les mêmes ambitions que
nous donc c'est capital aussi de
réfléchir sur cette souveraineté
alimentaire parce que comme je le disais
l'alimentation est une arme de guerre
nous l'avons nous le voyons
quotidiennement avec cette agression
russe de l'Ukraine quand les Ukrainiens
qui sont de gros producteurs notamment
de blé ne peuvent pas exporter notamment
dans les pays d'Afrique ça a des
conséquences considérables et on ça
démontre bien l'interaction aussi du
marché mondial donc l'Union européenne
on l'a fait dans le cadre de la
politique agricole commune doit
travailler sur le plus de revenus pour
ces agriculteurs la question du
changement climatique est la question de
la protection vis-à-vis des menaces en
quelque sorte et de la concurrence des
loyale
extra-européennes alors nous sommes ici
sur le stand des Vignerons Indépendants
comment ça se passe une journée pour un
eurodéputé ici au salon on va de
standard stand on a un agenda très
chargé au salon on essaye de rencontrer
le maximum de monde c'est aussi la
continuité d'un travail qu'on fait
quotidiennement effectivement vous avez
raison préciser qu'on est avec les
vignerons indépendants c'est les gens
c'est aussi la Confédération Européenne
des vignerons avec laquelle je travaille
au Parlement européen donc c'est
l'occasion de revoir de nombreux acteurs
avec qui on échange donc souvent
effectivement on multiplie l'ensemble
des visites hier notre délégation était
aussi présente au salon
l'interprofession les jeunes
agriculteurs la FNSEA l'intervention
dans des débats des échanges avec la
presse c'est un moment fort ce salon
aussi c'est l'occasion bien sûr de
retrouver les professionnels mais
d'échanger et de porter à la
connaissance de nos concitoyens
l'entièreté de ces enjeux parce qu'on le
voit qu'il y a une grosse pression aussi
sur le monde agricole et il faut
rappeler à quel point justement il joue
un rôle considérable pour nourrir
l'ensemble de la population vous l'avez
vous avez rencontré plusieurs
représentants ici du monde agricole
quels ont été les discours un petit peu
qu'ils vous ont qu'ils vous ont donné
quels sont les pistes envisagées est-ce
qu'ils parlent pour le futur ce qu'il
parle aussi de souveraineté alimentaire
c'est le sujet du moment bien sûr c'est
un sujet capital pour eux parce qu'ils
sont par exemple très heureux qu'on voit
le titre de ministre de l'Agriculture et
de la souveraineté alimentaire parce
qu'ils le disent depuis longtemps que
c'est un enjeu essentiel donc les
messages si je devais résumer entre deux
trois phrases on a souvent pas de
contraintes sans solution ça fait
référence par exemple aux décisions et à
la décision de la cour de 6 de l'Union
européenne sur les néonicotines donc on
va avoir tous ces nouveaux débats aussi
qui reviennent sur l'utilisation des
produits phytosanitaires au Parlement
européen sur les travaux qui m'occupe
plus particulièrement par le sur la
question du commerce international j'ai
été beaucoup interpellée sur la
multiplication des accords de
libre-échange spécifiquement sur le
parcours donc ce qui est dit en fait
c'est que au sein de l'Union européenne
on demande de plus en plus de choses de
normes qui sont vécues comme des
contraintes par nos agriculteurs alors
qu'ils ont parcouru déjà un chemin
important c'est ce qu'on a fait dans la
réforme de la Politique Agricole Commune
c'est ce qu'on appelle la stratégie de
la ferme à la fourchette et ce qu'ils
disent c'est que on ne peut pas avoir
des exigences à raison de plus en plus
forte et en même temps laisser des
produits rentrer sur notre marché
intérieur qui ne respectent pas
l'entièreté de ces normes de pro de
protection alors justement dans le même
temps que ce salon international de
l'agriculture il y a donc le dossier de
l'Accord de libre-échange UE merc qui
revient sur la table alors c'est un
dossier qui existe depuis très longtemps
on en parle et on en parlait déjà lors
des années 2000 en début des années 2000
le Mercosur donc revient sur la table
avec l'élection du président Lula au
Brésil qui donc le Brésil d'ailleurs une
autre grande puissance agricole quel est
l'intérêt d'un tel accord avec entre
l'Union européenne et le mercredi alors
de manière globale les accords de
commerce visa réguler les échanges à
ouvrir justement l'accès au marché pour
les Européens ou à la réciproque pour
celui avec qui vous concluez un accord
de commerce c'est établir des règles
pour justement nos échanges commerciaux
ce qu'on peut constater c'est que vous
avez raison de l'appeler avec donc avec
les pays du Mercosur donc le Brésil
l'Argentine l'Uruguay le Paraguay les
défenseurs de ce traité vous disent que
c'est important parce que c'est un grand
marché
et dans les accords de commerce on
traite énormément de sujets donc
264 millions de citoyens environ
exactement
vous disent qu'il est important de
conclure un accord de commerce avec ses
états avant la Chine notamment et vous
avez raison de souligner que l'arrivée
de Lula à la présidente du Brésil est
importante parce que nous n'avons plus
bolsonaro qui nous le savons à détruit
la relation internationale ont été très
peu compliquées avec
le Brésil et puis l'enjeu de la
déforestation donc l'accord de commerce
vise à instaurer certaines règles moi je
j'entends ceux qui disent l'entièreté de
ces éléments pour autant j'estime que
cet accord il est dépassé il est dans
notre temps l'accord ne peut pas être
accepté s'il n'y a pas les clauses
miroir et le respect du climat à
réaffirmer Emmanuel Macron ici au salon
de l'agriculture on est donc encore bien
loin d'un accord qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce
qui ne va pas du coup avec le Brésil
c'est le président de la République est
redit lors du salon ce message que nous
portons depuis de nombreuses années que
nous affirmons forts à la fois au
Conseil européen le président de la
République est à la fois au Parlement
européen j'avais fait adopter un
amendement dansant c'est la position du
Parlement européen c'est ce que je vous
disais en fait c'est que on demande de
plus en plus et pour autant on laisse
rentrer des produits qui ne respectent
pas ces normes sur l'entièreté de la
chaîne de Black production et c'est ça
les Claus miroir c'est la réciprocité
c'est de dire attention vous ne pouvez
pas rentrer sur notre marché intérieur
si vous ne les respectez pas et puis il
y a effectivement l'enjeu de respect de
l'accord de Paris parce que
ce que je dis souvent à mes collègues à
la Commission européenne conclure un
accord de commerce n'est pas une fin en
soi clairement pas l'enjeu c'est la mise
en oeuvre c'est de faire en sorte que
les engagements que vous avez obtenus
pendant ces négociations soient
réellement respectées et là on le voit
bien on aura face à nous des États qui
ne
même l'arrivée de Lula mais qui pourront
être enclin justement plutôt pour des
dans une logique d'exportation conduire
à la fois des conditions de concurrence
déloyale et à la fois augmenter la
déforestation alors qu'on nous on a cet
enjeu de lutter contre le dérèglement
climatique donc c'est
c'est quelque chose de très paradoxal
donc il nous faut réfléchir à une
nouvelle génération d'accords de
commerce à la fois dans le contenu des
négociations et dans le contenu des
accords et à la fois sur la forme parce
que vous le disiez le Mercosur ça fait
20 ans qu'on en débat on a un mandat de
négociation qui n'a pas évolué où il n'y
a pas eu suffisamment de contrôle
parlementaire donc moi j'invite le
commissaire d'ombrosky à revoir aussi la
méthodologie de négociation des accords
de commerce merci beaucoup Marie merci à
vous je rappelle que vous êtes heureux
débuter Rio Europe et donc
vice-président de la Commission du
commerce international au Parlement
européen
mais la Pâque ne fait pas toujours
l'unanimité certains défendent une autre
vision de l'agriculture j'ai rendez-vous
avec Benoît habiteau il est heureux
débuté membre du groupe Europe Écologie
Les Verts et vice-président de la
commission agriculture au Parlement
européen
qui est entrée en vigueur cette année
qu'est-ce que vous reprochez au système
actuel alors ce que je reproche à la
Pâque c'est que à la lumière de de
rapport notamment de la Cour des comptes
européennes on sait que la Pâques qu'on
a mis en place il y a 30 ans présente
des lacunes graves sur le revenu digne
des paysans sur le renouvellement des
générations sur les sujets pour lesquels
on a rendez-vous avec l'Histoire comme
le climat la biodiversité et la santé et
donc on avait l'occasion
dans le cadre de cette réflexion et
cette réforme de la PAC de corriger le
tir en plus la Cour des comptes nous
proposait des solutions et on les a pas
on les a pas emboîtés donc c'est c'est
vraiment dommage parce que les
scientifiques nous disent que le temps
presse on voit bien la rapidité à
laquelle disparaissent les paysans on
perd 50% des paysans 20 ans peut-être
encore 50% dans 10 ans et on voit bien
que on a une difficulté sur sur le
revenu des paysans et donc on avait une
occasion rêvée de pouvoir inverser ces
temps en dessous et on l'a pas fait
pourtant la Commission européenne mais
en avant une Pâque plus verte avec
notamment ses écorigimes 25% des aides
directes aux agriculteurs pour
encourager les bonnes pratiques
environnementales ça ne va pas assez
loin selon vous pour l'environnement et
pour cette ambition en tout cas qui est
affichée mais déjà ça n'est que 25%, ça
veut dire en creux que 75% continuent
d'être distribués sans réel
conditionnalités climatiques
environnementales sanitaire donc c'est
quand même trop peu et puis on aurait dû
changer le cœur du réacteur c'est à dire
que tous les mécanismes que décrit la
Cour des comptes notamment sur le revenu
des agriculteurs et le renouvellement
des générations mais aussi sur la
problématique de de la conditionnalité
et de d'une pacte plus environnementale
nous inviter à changer à changer de le
cœur du réacteur moi j'appelle le coeur
du réacteur et donc si on a arrêté de
distribuer les aides par unité de
surface qui ne profite facile à
comprendre qu'à ceux qui ont beaucoup de
surfaces on aurait inversé cette
tendance lourdes si on avait non pas sur
25% mais sur la totalité de l'enveloppe
poser des règles de conditionnalité on
aurait vraiment avancé sur une Pâque qui
à la fois rémunir mieux ses paysans
encourage le renouvellement des
générations et au rendez-vous de
l'histoire sur climat biodiversité et
santé alors vous Benoit Pitot vous vous
êtes devenu agriculteur à l'âge de 40
ans vous avez une ferme en
Charente-Maritime une ferme 100%
biologique en agriculture biologique
qu'est-ce qui vous a donné envie de se
de faire ce métier cette reconversion en
tout cas d'engager cette reconversion et
comment se porte votre votre ferme
aujourd'hui alors moi je suis tombé
dedans je suis tombé dans la marmite
quand j'étais tout petit c'est à dire
que je suis fils d'agriculteur
petit-fils de paysan j'ai toujours
grandi dans ce monde là donc forcément
quand on a on a cette histoire là on a
envie de un jour le vivre pour soi-même
et puis après moi j'ai un parcours de
scientifique d'anciens chercheurs où
j'ai côtoyé des agriculteur qui était
heureux de faire leur métier qui était
un bien inséré socialement enfin voilà
et donc ces expériences là m'ont amené à
me dire qu'il fallait que je passe à
l'acte pour moi-même et c'était
intéressant parce que je partais d'une
structure qui était allée très loin dans
un modèle productiviste industriel
intensif et et en partant de là en
pratiquant l'agroécologie j'ai aussi
fait la démonstration que que des
alternatives étaient possibles et que
sans impacter le rôle fondamental de
l'agriculture de satisfaire la
souveraineté alimentaire de rémunérer
bien ses paysans on pouvait aussi
agir en direction du climat de la
biodiversité de la santé et aujourd'hui
cette structure se porte très très bien
c'est à dire que dans le contexte du
moment où un certain nombre de secteurs
agricoles traversent des difficultés et
bien moi ma ferme je peux le dire se
porte très très bien alors la question
de l'élevage c'est de l'un de vos
combats on le sait aussi vous lutter
contre l'élevage intensif industriel
vous souhaitez les interdire
c'est plus subtil que ça je pense que
l'interdiction c'est pas forcément la
bonne méthode c'est à dire que c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'écologie punitive moi je
préfère et ça nous renvoie sur le débat
sur la PAC je préfère les incitations au
changement c'est-à-dire et c'est ça
qu'on a loupé avec cette pack c'est à
dire que si on considère que ces
élevages là ne remplissent pas les
fonctions qu'on attend de l'agriculture
sur la santé le climat et la
biodiversité encore une fois mais aussi
sur le revenu des paysans sur le
renouvellement des générations il faut
changer et donc il faut cesser de
perfuser cette agriculture là avec les
aides publiques et faire en sorte que
ces aides publiques encouragent la
transition et et les élevages
industriels effectivement il faut qu'on
arrête parce que sur le climat c'est pas
la bonne réponse sur le bien-être animal
c'est pas la bonne réponse sur la
biodiversité c'est pas la bonne réponse
et sur le revenu des paysans c'est pas
la bonne réponse non plus et donc il
faut il faut inverser cette tendance
lourde pour autant il ne faut pas
renoncer à l'élevage quelles sont
aujourd'hui les les freins aux
alternatives à l'élevage intensif
pourquoi les agriculteurs aujourd'hui
sont entre guillemets fichiers freiné à
développer davantage une agriculture
biologique peut-être ou à taille un peu
plus réduite ben c'est c'est le rôle des
politiques publiques justement c'est à
dire que si les politiques publiques
étaient étaient mieux orientés on ne
perfusait plus économiquement des choix
d'entreprise qui ne sont plus les bons
au regard des attentes sociétales et
citoyenne et qu'on René qu'on remobilise
et ses crédits sur l'accompagnement des
alternatives dans un objectif de
rémunérer et le mot est important de
rémunérer des agriculteurs qui font bien
qui prennent soin du climat de la
biodiversité et de la santé avec les
aides publiques de la PAC et bien on
aurait des activités d'élevage qui sont
tournées vers l'entretien de prairies
remarquables qui séquestre du carbone
vers des prêts remarquables qui
hébergent de la biodiversité et qui en
plus produisent du lait de la viande
d'extrêmement bonne qualité
contrairement à du lait et de la viande
produit avec des élevages qui qui
fonctionnent avec le binôme maïs soja
dont on connaît par ailleurs les dégâts
sur la ressource en eau sur le climat
dernière dernier sujet avec vous Benoît
Biteau la consommation de viande on sait
que la tendance a été ces dernières
années à une légère baisse en tout cas
dans par rapport à la consommation
globale en France est-ce que la
transition donc de l'élevage notamment
doit passer obligatoirement également à
côté par une une baisse encore de la
consommation
oui il faudra et moi je mets la viande
et les produits laitiers d'ailleurs donc
tous les produits issus de cet élevage
industriels doivent drastiquement
baisser parce que je répète mais c'est
mon triptyque l'élevage industriel n'est
pas
ne sont pas des pratiques qui vont qui
vont dans le sens de la protection du
climat de la biodiversité de la santé en
revanche un élevage tourné vers des
systèmes herbagiques participent à une
meilleure santé du mangeur mais aussi du
climat de la biodiversité et donc on a
intérêt à ce que ne perdure que ces
pratiques d'élevage là tourner vers des
systèmes herbagés sur des prairies de
montagne sur des prairies de zones
humides ou il remplissent toutes ces
fonctions là mais si on ne limite
l'élevage qu'à ses activités là
effectivement il y aura beaucoup moins
de lait et de viande disponibles et donc
il faut effectivement dans nos attitudes
alimentaires envisager une réduction
importante de notre consommation de lait
et de viande pour finir pour autant il
faut en manger encore mieux moins mieux
pour finir la mi-temps un mot sur le
salon de l'agriculture c'est la 59e
édition cette année qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de cet événement
c'est un moment incontournable pour pour
l'agriculture européenne internationale
même après moi la seule critique que je
que j'ai à proposer sur ce salon c'est
que on est en train de nous présenter un
peu une image d'Épinal de l'agriculture
on est en train de d'activer chez nous
dans notre généalogie notre référence à
des ancêtres qui étaient paysans sauf
que cette agriculture elle n'existe plus
et donc je pense qu'il est urgent de de
constater et d'entendre la demande de la
société civile si ce salon est fréquenté
c'est parce que les gens sont en
recherche de cette agriculture là qui
fait référence à nos racines paysanne et
donc il faut entendre ça dans le
développement agricole de manière à ce
que le message que nous envoie les gens
qui fréquentent ce salon infusent dans
l'évolution des pratiques agricoles
merci beaucoup Bruno merci à vous
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes heureux député membre du
groupe Europe écologie des Verts au
Parlement européen et premier
vice-président de la commission
agriculture au Parlement européen merci
beaucoup
zone Europe c'est terminé vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en replay sur
notre site internet sur notre
application radio sensation et aussi sur
TV 78 on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un prochain numéro bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]